haiya listen to this Donald Trump is the
candidate on illegal immigration right
he has said countless times that it is
only because of him that anybody in the
Republican Party and now the
presidential race is talking about
illegal immigration he's gonna build the
wall he's gonna make Mexico pay for it
he's going to ban Muslims from countries
with ties to terrorism from coming to
the u.s. until we can quote figure out
what the hell is going on because he
won't tolerate or abet illegal
immigration however that's obviously
nonsense the Muslim ban would be
unconstitutional the wall would be
outrageously expensive and not even that
useful and there is no way that Mexico
is paying for it it is widely known that
Trump himself has worked with
contractors in the buildings that he
builds that employ undocumented
immigrants we knew all that but now this
is amazing it is increasingly apparent
that Donald Trump's wife Melania Trump
has not been completely upfront in the
story of her immigration to the United
States from her birth country of
Slovenia can you imagine if the
anti-illegal immigration candidate is
married to a woman who was working in
the United States illegally it appears
that that is the case let's talk it
through Melania Trump has long claimed
that she first came to the u.s. in 96
and that she followed the rules here is
a quote from what she said too bizarre
earlier this year you follow the rules
you follow the law every few months you
need to fly back to Europe and stamp
your visa after a few visas I applied
for a green card and got it in 2001
pretty innocuous right well not really
Politico noticed that the nude photos of
her that were recently reprinted on the
cover of the New York Post are from 1995
and appear to have been taken in the
United States neat both facts neither of
which has been refuted why does this
matter well Melania Trump in describing
reapplying for her visa by leaving the
country and coming back every few months
is implying that you are not on an h-1b
working visa because an h-1b working
visa last three years and can be renewed
within the United States you don't have
to leave to reapply to renew your h-1b
working visa that's the visa that would
allow her to work in the United States
what Melania Trump has described this
leaving reapplying and coming back would
be if she had a B one temporary business
visitor visa or a b2 tourist visa what's
important about those visas Louis
neither allow the visa holder to work in
the US if Melania Trump worked in the
United States while in the country on
either the visitor business visitor or
tourist visa that means that she was
illegally working in the u.s.
effectively an illegal immigrant now she
responded by saying the following this
is from Twitter in recent days there has
been a lot of inaccurate information
inaccurate reporting and misinformation
concerning my immigration status as far
back as 1996 back in 1996 let me set the
record straight
I have at all times been in full
compliance with the immigration laws of
this country period any allegation to
the contrary is untrue in July of 2006 I
proudly became a US citizen over the
past 20 years I have been fortunate to
live work and raise a family in this
great nation and I share my husband's
love for our country unfortunately this
is not an explanation Louis of why she
would be leaving the country reapplying
and coming back while working in the US
because that would mean she was working
without authorization that is an
illegally that is an action of illegal
immigration status period and she still
has not explained that well you know it
doesn't really matter if you are working
illegally or here illegally if you're an
attractive Slovenian it only matters if
you're Mexican or Muslim so there has
been more to the story an immigration
attorney who worked for the Trump
Organization told Univision that Melania
Trump obtained a green card based on
marriage in 2001 there is one potential
problem with that
that was four years before she married
Donald Trump well maybe she was married
to somebody else in the United States
right that would explain it well she
told Larry King in 2005 she was never
married before meeting Donald Trump not
to mention this entire conversation is
about 2001 for
and the time in question is 1995 and
1996 if Donald Trump wanted President
Obama's birth certificate way more
documentation is in order here because
we have some actual questions about the
immigration status of Donald Trump's
wife Donald Trump of course the
anti-illegal immigration candidate yeah
well Donald Trump is already doing a
great job destroying himself this this
probably won't add too much fuel to the
fire
the Democratic coalition against Trump
has filed a Freedom of Information Act
request for some of these documents we
will see what we find out